Born in Philadelphia on August 23, 1978,...
...Kobe was the only son of former NBA player Joe "Jellybean" Bryant.
A sensation at his high school outside Philadelphia,...
...he decided to bypass college and go directly to the NBA.
He was made the number 13 pick in the NBA draft by the Charlotte Hornets,...
...who then traded him to the Lakers in July 1996.
A five-time NBA champion and 18-time all-star,...
...Kobe is the Lakers' franchise leader in points, games played,...
...three-pointers, steals and free throws.
He became the first player to spend at least 20 seasons with one franchise...
...and retired in 2016 with a 60-point performance at his farewell game against Utah.
One of the most tenacious and clutch players in NBA history,...
...the 6-foot-6 Kobe who gave himself the nickname "Black Mamba", once scored 81 points in a game.
He was selected as league's most valuable player in 2008,...
...and named MVP of the NBA Finals in 2009 and 2010.
His uniform numbers 8 and 24 have been retired by the Lakers.
In 2018, Kobe won the best animated short Oscar...
...for his five-minute autobiographical film, Dear Basketball.
He wrote, executive-produced, and lent his voice to the project.